professionnels de santé chercheurs et
élus de l'agglomération se sont réunis
au sein de l'ufr santé de l'université
saint quentin en yvelines pour le
lancement d'un projet imaginé depuis
déjà deux ans la création d'un hôpital
virtuel à l'hôpital virtuel ça va
d'abord un bâtiment c'est du solide et à
l'intérieur va mettre ça on va
rencontrer au fait à l'hôpital mais avec
tout virtuel c'est à dire des mannequins
pour la simulation
on va avoir des salles de chirurgie des
salles d'obstétrique des salles de
pédiatrie des salles de consultation
sérieux une plateforme de simulation de
haut niveau trois axes stratégiques sont
imaginer un développement de l'offre de
soins avec notamment la télémédecine un
renforcement de la formation mais
également la création d'un living lab
pour encourager la recherche
il a besoin de réinventer le chu il ya
besoin de réinventer la place du chu
dans les territoires parce que voilà
c'est pas un scoop de dire que la
majorité de nos citoyennes de
concitoyens se plaignent de difficultés
d'accès aux soins d'accès à la
prévention d'accès à l'éducation en
matière de santé et bien là cet espace
cette expérimentation du chu de demain a
pour objectif pour ambition de répondre
à ces besoins de la population
le bâtiment de 5000 m² s'inscrit dans le
contrat local de santé de saint quentin
en yvelines l'agglomération apporte le
foncier et se montre actrice pour
trouver les financements
cet hôpital virtuelle dans le cadre de
ce contrat local de sécurité au même
titre que nous sommes à la pointe pour
tout ce qui concerne le développement
numérique au même titre que nous soyons
nous espérons et nous serons à la pointe
au niveau de tout ce qui est
cybersécurité voilà c'est un événement
de pointe dans lequel notre territoire
souhaite s'inscrire dans les mois et les
années à venir
un sachet du futur pour pallier
l'absence de centres hospitaliers
universitaires dans les yvelines à
l'heure actuelle objectif rêvée pour le
doyen de l'ufr santé une ouverture pour
les jeux olympiques de 2024